et alors cela grippe aviaire qu'est-ce
que vous avez inventé alors Fred
vous allez vous allez vous [__] de ma
gueule
alors Fred vargaz vous sortez chez
Viviane ami un nouveau polar qui
s'appelle dans les bois éternelles mais
vous êtes ici ce soir avant tout pour
parler du livre de César et batisti
publié chez Grasset Rivas préfacé par
Bernard Henri Lévy post fassé par vous
qui s'appelle ma cavale mais qu'est-ce
que tu reproches au Resto du Coeur
exactement
alors ça s'appelle ma cavale et dans ce
livre depuis sa cavale du bout du monde
moins que ce soit au bout de la rue on
sait pas Baptiste Tiron le silence et se
justifie sur les raisons de sa fuite
c'est une sorte de plaidoirie dont il
pourrait bénéficier s'il avait droit à
un nouveau procès en Italie ce qui n'est
pas le cas alors on va faire un espèce
de flashback sur l'affaire baptisti donc
dans les années de plan en Italie
Baptiste et membre d'un groupe husq le
gauchiste accusé d'assassinat combien de
voilà et il est condamné à perpétuité en
Italie pas pour ça
il est livré par un commando armé et
pour d'autres affaires le concernant il
est jugé par contumace et au procès il
est chargé par son ancien collègue du
groupe sculpack qui s'appelle Mouti qui
est un repenti et donc qui le charge qui
dit c'est lui le responsable c'est lui
le responsable évidemment comme font
tous les repentis alors baptisti s'en va
au Mexique où il fait des petits boulots
pendant 9 ans et en 1990 Mitterrand
accorde l'asile politique aux ex
terroristes italiens et il vient
s'installer à Paris où il est gardiens
d'immeubles et auteurs chez Gallimard
voilà alors en 2002 Berlusconi demande
son extradition à la France et la France
Renise ce qu'on appelle la doctrine
Mitterrand c'est d'ailleurs la
protection de ces extérés Italiens et
accepte donc l'extradition de baptisti
qui part en cavale et en cavale il écrit
dit c'est ça ou mourir c'est assez
poignant d'ailleurs quand il en parle
quoi c'est vraiment il se raccroche à ce
bouquin à l'écriture de ce bouquin
comme une bouée de sauvetage dans
l'océan quoi c'est sûr qu'il a écrit
pour survivre ça sent à travers chaque
ligne et pour s'expliquer puisqu'il a
jamais eu de procès c'est tout ce qui
demande il n'a jamais pu s'expliquer de
ce dont on l'accuse baptisti dit je n'ai
pas tué il dit je n'ai jamais tué
personne c'est vrai j'ai participé à ce
groupe uscule mais je n'ai jamais tué
personne voilà
c'est vrai bon présomption d'innocence
qu'il faut entendre oui de toute façon
ça n'a rien à voir mais où trop nous a
quand même montré tragiquement que il
fallait qu'on est obligé d'écouter
quelqu'un qu'il dit et qui a été accusé
par le chef du groupe donc Baptiste
était pas du tout chef de ce groupe
c'est le chef et fondateur du groupe
très radical pietremouti dont il fait un
très joli portrait d'ailleurs très fin
qui une fois baptisti partie depuis un
an quand il s'est fait choper encore les
armes à la main lui était lui il était
accusé de meurtre donc il avait la
perpète en face et il a tout chargé avec
d'autres du groupe sur les épaules de
l'absent
toujours tort
exemplaire
moi je le dis oui voilà l'extrême gauche
mais non moi je défends aucune sorte de
violence nulle part il a pas eu de
procès il a jamais eu de procès Baptiste
pour ses homicides il était pas là
et la France a depuis des siècles
inventé un truc commun entre
l'accusation et la prison à vie en plus
comme qui s'appelle un procès qu'un truc
assez malin où on a le droit de se
défendre soit devant ses juges de ce que
nous est reprochés il n'a jamais eu je
me bats parce que la France l'a extradé
c'est l'envoient directement en prison à
perpétuité sans procès et donc il a le
droit à un procès statistique comme
n'importe qui d'où qu'il vient et quoi
qu'il est fait bon après là on a
commencé à discuter d'innocence mais il
se trouve qu'il a pas commission meurtre
c'est vrai mais même si les avait commis
je demanderai que tout homme toute femme
tout gosse est un procès
le renvoie en Italie il ira en prison à
perpétuité sans jamais avoir été jugé
c'est ça votre problème parce qu'on
Italie c'est le seul pays d'Europe ou
quand on attrape un contumas c'est à
dire un condamné en son absence on a le
droit de l'emprisonner directement nulle
part ailleurs c'est à dire que la France
a rompu sa loi sur les condamnés absents
les contumas en acceptant qu'un homme
voilà si c'est très amusant comme on a
fait pour briser la loi vous êtes pas
trop d'accord avec ça vous êtes ça
dépend sur quoi tu réservé ouais je suis
plus réservé pour deux raisons il y a un
point sur lequel je suis entièrement
d'accord François Mitterrand président
de la République française a donné sa
parole et et ça a été confirmé ensuite
par des gouvernements qui n'étaient pas
des gouvernements socialistes donc il y
a eu un consensus à condition que ceux
qui étaient protégés par cette règle qui
n'est pas une règle de droit que le fait
à condition qu'il ne fasse plus de
terrorisme or ils n'ont plus fait de
terrorisme ce sont des ex terroristes
qui sont à la retraite ou mission ils
font des romans ils travaillent là-bas
ce sont des gens donc on doit garder
qu'on ne doit pas rendre si il y a
quelque chose de très de très choquant
dans l'idée qu'il y a des fugitifs comme
ça qu'on va livrer alors qu'on a promis
de pas le faire ça ça me
donc sur ce point là je trouve que la
campagne baptisti est parfaitement
justifiée mais il y a deux choses qui me
frappent la première c'est que en Italie
toutes sortes de gens ont dit mais vous
êtes fou tous ces gens là c'était des
terroristes n'oubliez pas et donc ils
ont un son de cloche très différent en
Italie et en France y compris dans des
cercles qui ne sont pas du tout des
cercles répressifs ou d'extrême droite
ou je ne sais quoi ce sont des cercles
démocratiques alors ce qui vous frappe
aujourd'hui c'est qu'on défend ici
quelqu'un qui en fait est considéré par
ses compatriotes comme un terroriste
quoi oui non mais je ne suis contre
l'extradition clair je suis conte qu'on
l'extrade bon ça c'est certaines choses
alors il y a une deuxième chose qui me
gêne mais ça c'est pas du tout le cas de
Fred Vargas mais dans la campagne
probatistique autour il y a quand même
l'idée sous-jacente qu'on va donner une
version de ce qui s'est passé pendant
ces années de plan qui était d'une Corée
et qui finalement est largement falsifié
ça consiste à dire oui mais alors à
l'époque vous comprenez il y avait une
sorte de guerre civile entre deux
entités ce qu'on met sur le même plan
et moi je ne fais pas l'apologie de
l'extrême gauche armée je répète une
fois de plus c'est pas mon problème mon
problème c'est que je ne veux pas je ne
considère pas ça normal en France pour
lui ou quiconque qu'un homme dont on ne
sait pas s'il a fait ou pas ce qu'on lui
reproche ayant à perpétuité sans qu'ils
se soient qu'on lui donne une fois la
possibilité une fois de s'expliquer
devant ses juges et quand je lisais tout
à l'heure un éditorial dans l'Express
qui disait il est lâche il est en fuite
alors qu'il devrait avoir le courage de
se présenter devant la justice certes
mais quelle justice il y a pas de procès
de prévu pour lui et j'aimerais bien
qu'il ait un procès lui aussi voulait le
demander avec des observateurs
internationaux par sécurité et je m'en
ferai pas puisqu'il a pas tué ses gars
donc vous trouvez normal comme
bernard-henille écrit dans la préface du
bouquin qu'il soit en cavale tant qu'il
a pas un procès donc il a pas
l'assurance comme tout le monde comme
comme moi n'importe qui de pouvoir dire
bon c'est que ces quatre meurtres on me
les fous sur le dos voilà ce qui s'est
passé voilà où j'étais enfin bon de
s'expliquer qu'il y ait des preuves des
contrefa il y a pas une preuve dans
l'affaire Baptiste il y a que des
paroles de repentir de dissocier qui ont
été libérés parce que pieds trop Mouti
qui était accusé de meurtre il a été
libéré au bout de 8 ans de service
auprès du jugement de ce patin aux
commandes baptisti c'est le seul absent
du groupe qui s'est pris une perpétuité
dans les packs et donc quand il est
revenu à 91 il a appris qu'il avait sur
le dos tous les meurtres des Pâques
alors qu'il était sorti précisément du
groupe pour pour cette raison trop de
sang comme il explique donc c'est il y a
quelque chose qui va pas il faut qu'on
écoute cet homme qu'on enlève le torrent
de haine qui s'est déversé sur lui de
manière irrationnelle qu'on se calme
qu'on écoute cet homme et qu'on regarde
si on veut pas c'est pas un moyen de lui
faire un procès ou si on peut pas on
l'extrape pas mais qu'est-ce qui va se
passer alors revenir à l'ancienne
jurisprudence c'était une grande sagesse
au fond ça consiste à dire
bon
on va pas pour chasser un définiment les
gens même quand ils ont commis ce qu'ils
ont commis si on obtient en échange de
d'une sorte d'indulgence c'est une
protection le fait qui quitte la lutte
armée et qu'ils arrêtent le terrorisme
en Italie c'était plutôt bien vu de
faire ça ça a rendu service d'une
certaine manière à la démocratie
italienne parce qu'il y en a eu des
centaines qui sont qui ont poussé la
frontière et puis qui sont rangés et ça
s'est arrêté surtout qu'ils avaient déjà
arrêté batistil est sorti de la
lutermelle 9 mai 78 c'est exactement ça
fait 28 ans
c'est pas des il avait jamais tiré sur
personne
on a parfois tendance à présenter
l'Italie comme un pays ultra répressif
les ravisseurs de l'album ils sont
sortis
on a jugé ceux qui étaient responsables
de l'attentat de la Piazza Fontana et
finalement les a tous l'italien les a
tous acquittés
qu'ils avaient été accusés par des
repentis et que la parole des repentis
n'est pas fiable alors qu'est-ce qu'on
fait prise en compte
européenne des droits de l'homme donc il
y en a un cours européenne des droits de
l'homme il a naturalisation aussi
peut être naturalisé
c'est naturalisation quand il était en
prison quand il est en prisonnier trois
semaines en 2004
comment ça se fait que d'un seul coup
vous êtes devenu comme ça focalisé sur
l'affaire baptistique comme si c'était
comme si vous étiez Voltaire et si
c'était l'affaire Calas bon quand
baptiste est arrivé ça a croisé ma route
ah là ça va pas non plus j'ai une des
dernières à signer qu'on dise pas que je
m'emballe pour un oui pour un an j'ai
dit non moi je suis pas parce que c'est
un gars qui crée du polar faut pas
déconner on va pas faire du corporatisme
idiot donc comme je suis historienne
archéologue quand même j'ai compulsé mon
dossier on dit mais tu nous emmerde
sinon je travaille d'abord j'ai
travaillé ensuite j'ai vu que ça
n'allait pas du tout cette affaire et
qu'elle était le marché
j'ai signé et ensuite j'ai continué à
travailler c'est mon drame c'est que je
travaille une fois que je suis démarré
un boulot
que ça vous allez jusqu'au ouais c'est
la vérité enfouie sous le tonne de
gravats ça m'énerve donc faut la dégager
on peut aujourd'hui d'avoir faim et ça
dépend
des dramatisons quand même parce qu'au
bout
d'un moment donné de moi une image de
des dramatisant se fait partie de la vie
des combats de la vie il y en a plein
d'autres il y en a beaucoup celui-là est
très médiatisé on le voit donc mais bon
baptisti c'est le premier avoir des fous
rires même avant son extradition avec
Guy Bedos c'est tout qui disait
qu'est-ce qu'on arrive avec l'affaire
Baptiste alors il est où il est où
Baptiste là si je le savais je ne vous
le dirai pas je ne sais pas je pense que
comme il est pas si idiot s'il y avait
quelqu'un avec qui devait se mettre en
contact comme homme un peu trop de
visibilité dans l'affaire Baptiste pour
que les historiens je vais appeler Fred
non je lui conseille pas
non moi je suis sur écoute
je sais plus
[Rires]
[Musique]
je me suis désherbatif
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
et puis à ça aussi alors dans les bois
éternelles votre nouveau polar mais qui
passe un peu à l'AS avec tout ça mais
vous en foutez vous en vendez beaucoup
de toute façon non
ça marche bien
qu'est-ce que vous avez inventé alors
Fred
vous allez vous [__] de ma gueule pas
du tout je sais ce que vous avez inventé
vous avez inventé un grand manteau en
matière plastique transparent pour pas
trouver de la peste parce qu'en fait ça
se transmet c'est ça l'analyse qu'il y
en aura pas
problème de production et de quantité la
grippe elle arrivera bon à 90% de risque
ça veut dire quoi 90% tous les chambres
d'épidémiologie calcule le risque de
mutation à 90% de probabilité voire 100%
donc elle arrive là
si on avait des masques il faut des
lunettes parce que ça rentre par les
mucuses des yeux et puis c'est un
aérosol quand on se parle on est à
combien ces 3 mètres max on éternuement
ou en tout de mettre en parole donc
c'est un bouteille de viande quand donc
ça se dépose l'aérosol dans les cheveux
et pourquoi il nous le disent pas ça la
télévision alors je le dis ça se dépose
partout donc 60% des rhumes à peu près
on les attrape on arrive dans un café on
fait ça on ramasse l'aérosol des
gouttelettes de flugs et les
gouttelettes de petits enfin ça
s'appelle des postillons microscopiques
et donc comme le virus de la grippe vie
trois quatre heures à l'air libre
si on fait ça et qu'après on fait ça en
disant c'est bien et tranquille dans ce
café donc la cape faut pas manger testé
à la maison
le Z derrière
il faudra qu'on puisse être autonome ne
pas se mettre dans les mains du
gouvernement qui ne pourra pas alimenter
les gens à quarantaine vu qu'il y a pas
de masque qui c'est qui va le faire nous
apporter à manger donc en fait ce qu'il
faut éviter c'est la dislocation sociale
l'épidémie tombe en trois jours on
devient des brutes il faut le savoir il
faut arriver à avoir une autonomie
pendant une ou deux heures pour aller
faire ses courses un par indispensable
qu'on se remette pas comme des bébés en
disant que fait l'étal est un pourra pas
faire grand chose et le Tamiflu c'est
très compliqué parce que ça marche dans
les 48 heures de la teinte alors les
gars les médecins comment ils savent en
48 heures où sont les hypocondriaques
les grippes avières et les grippes
saisonnières donc avec une cape on sort
cap en plastique transparent mais on
peut la on peut la taguer on peut faire
des trucs marrant je suis sûr que vous
allez abandonner
en dessous de blaguer
et la cape l'intéresse c'est de forcer
le virus intrant à s'impacter sur le
plastique et descendre jusqu'au sol pour
qu'il aille se condenser avec les
gouttelettes ou s'il est toujours au sol
tandis que nous on pense que le virus va
frapper un mardi gras c'est la seule
région qu'on se pose quoi ça
paraît alors
pour les angoisser moi je suis resté une
heure de sous c'est naturel oui deux
maintenant
deux comme ça on respire normalement on
voit quelqu'un à 5 mètres pour les
hypocondriaques 10 mètres on referme les
fermetures c'est comme les voitures code
phare code phare mais ça va durer un
mois
c'est rien
si on met la cape je n'auras pas parce
que il y a une place dans les hôpitaux
avec Mamie
c'est un prototype
l'intéresse que je veux c'est un truc
qu'on puisse fabriquer à la maison parce
que qu'on retombe pas ce problème des
masses et être tributaire une chaîne de
production qui ne pour
RA pas donc ce qui m'amuse c'est de voir
si on peut effectivement le fabriquer à
la maison le truc dans le dos en fait
c'est un fil de fer très fin pour que le
plastique reste là qu'on l'embête pas
oui mais c'est c'est intéressant
un livret sans masque
merci d'avoir été avec nous
pour être sûr de ne rien rater de
innarditube abonnez-vous et mettez un
pouce bleu